[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys
everybody hey y'all like to say what
nick
uh is some something with me sucking
dicks something about nickelodeon all
right yeah
we're going to do something a little bit
fun today
do you have the tune yet no i'm
practicing okay
we're going to play a little bit of hot
seat with our boy silent mike over here
you do know the game are you lying kind
of well this is our first time doing it
oh it's the first time
i love it i don't know if it's too low
i'm very strong that's how we can move a
thousand swords
is this gonna hold me is this
no they can see me you're too small am i
awkwardly just sitting in frame like
this should i move breaking i was trying
to just wield my weapon because i have
one be careful should i move over to
this side that's a one-on-one
wait why are you moving to this side i
don't know he's in the hot seat no he's
next to you all right [ __ ] are we
getting weird in here we're gonna get
weird we're getting a little weird we're
just testing out new show ideas we're
gonna test out some [ __ ] we just want to
play a little hottie because we're still
[ __ ] fun
plus we're all a little bit dgm like
that everybody's gonna ask you just a
series of questions he's getting there
he's getting there did you have it
it's really helping
i feel like i'm at a renaissance fair
all right we have unlimited amount of
time to put you in an unlimited amount
of uncomfort discomfort so that's the
hot seat where we ask the hot questions
can you see his eyes that's how we do it
and we'll start with cold ones and it
gets warmer the last question's about to
be a hitter yeah we'll see so i'll start
it off
first question is uh
um so people know you from fitness yeah
how did you get into fitness oh that's
cold dude that's ice cold yeah it's iced
coffee that's cold if you get bored
though we're gonna cut your ass right
now yeah it's this is boring uh i play
basketball my whole life um obviously
not very tall if you guys can't tell i'm
not built much like a basketball player
so i got into
uh lifting to kind of be faster or
stronger you lie you were you got it to
[ __ ] some girls yeah i said dude just
looking for the seventh grade hoes
for sex you gotta you got to do seventh
grade you want to be strong yeah seventh
and eighth grade your motivation was
just to be strong how old were you when
you first had sex
uh high school junior
16 how'd you do
yeah so you're not a honest review was
it pretty good oh i mean for me yeah
great
you're not a virgin no okay that's a hot
question better after you started
lifting
oh that's a good question we're on
patreon how deep we get in this thing as
deep as you want not on patreon
[Laughter]
balls deep uh
yeah i think fitness definitely helps
well sure
like from multiple standpoints i was
talking about needs analysis of sex for
i even told bart uh like morning wood
common male trait right especially
hopefully i love it yeah best time of my
life i can't even tell i take a couple
months off lifting heavy like you don't
get morning wood oh no you still get it
i went through some like mental stuff so
i just stopped lifting and then i
started deadlifting like a savage again
it gets like i don't know about longer
but if you like feel it but it's harder
it's going hey hey i bet you know this
hard boner and then i had a hard boner
i bet i bet you know this more than
anybody here because you're a fitness
dude but then i heard that heavy lifting
also jacks up testosterone for sure and
it's not gonna do like anything crazy
like you if you can't get a boner
lifting might not fix that but within a
natural range it'll help i just like
that your cell is
yeah it really brings it for your
morning
so then like the logistics too right
like like endurance et cetera et cetera
i'm gonna do more dead lives dude i i
like having brothers
i'm like disappointing my morning
when i'm all alone i mean you're asking
a single guy what do you know i gotta
get up and go to work a little bit that
was that was warm but you don't like
jacking off i turn up no i hate it
in the fitness realm
uh do you have a crush can i tell a
story yeah yeah an embarrassing one a
public figures fitness person question
that's finding out for the first time
who watches this channel yes uh so the
so i don't know about that but uh do you
know jamie eason
yeah old school old school so one of my
first muscle babe crushes uh i love
muscle baby dude so
i need a photo reference
make a crush on her uh like my whole
life uh teenage years probably whenever
i she's uh like a bodybuilding.com
spokesperson right yeah yeah yeah i
remember i remember her oh easton price
bart [ __ ] jack off all over her
anything i say right now and i can't
embarrass more than the story already
embarrassed jamie jamie eason middleton
this one right here hi jamie she looks
like a straight milf dude
oh you know her and she's watching right
now she's dancing she might follow my
instagram hello yo she got like a family
channel now have you met her before uh
not in person do you know she has seven
kids
or one you
show what no
you're dead away at a crush
up their marriage like i can send you so
i so uh have a crush on jamie for a long
time right like teenage muscle crush
right and then uh and then my career
expands expands i'm vlogging or whatever
and i had a long conversation at a
dinner actually with some of the barbell
guys and we're vlogging and some of the
guys were talking about masturbating uh
in the bathroom like when you gotta do a
kind of secret you know and some kids
told me they mastered first thing we can
get your guys i'm whipping this hot take
back around on you some of these some of
these kids said they jerked off sitting
down on a toilet
yeah no as a kid
i was a teenager or whatever who [ __ ]
did it no no you stand up like your pee
it's like
an embarrassing thing
i've done plenty of embarrassing things
i [ __ ] couches i [ __ ] love seats i
[ __ ] recliners no you haven't not the
way i have you know jack off sitting
down i don't check out sitting down on
the toilet
you go to the bathroom what do you do
you do you take one
i do the opposite of what of sexual
things no because sometimes after you
take a [ __ ] you're like i need a rubber
now no never you can leave that there
when i smell my own poo i can't get a
boner it depends on how i can't actually
if the toilet's been really bad i smack
you you spit on it
you guys are [ __ ] weird you don't sit
down while you touch yourself and you
definitely don't do it after you poo
because then it's the whole room smells
like the weirdest thing about that was
that bart has a bidet that was the
weirdest thing for me
so it's shooting water back at you all
kinds of places
long story short uh i worked with reebok
for a while and i was one of their
sponsored athletes in it and then they
signed jamie and when when they signed
some folks sometimes they'll show like
hey dude that girl got a eight pack dude
they said like this is the team you know
like hey you this guy's saw him like
he's out in the west coast so you rubbed
one out to her before no oh but probably
i don't know that's beside the point
these are listen listen listen now your
teammates are like well i remember you
so i even told cause the guy who manages
me there's a buddy you know i'm like oh
you signed jamie bro i had the fattest
pressure on her oh cool like i showed
her your youtube that was so cool then
like a week later that's the vlog that
came out and we're talking about jerking
off everywhere and then when she i think
she does dm me or like we just
introduced you so she's like yeah
interesting youtube content i was like
oh
there goes any chance i mean
you i mean she still was willing to dm
you something she was like business
she gave you a winky winky no i didn't
get a winky she's married i would never
this is years ago no she was probably
married then it was just this is when
she only had four kids it was just a
coincidence of my weirdest perfect time
for you to slide in dude so that was
your that was your fitness that was your
fitness crush that's probably the first
one i can think of maybe like a china or
something but you never
you know who it's about talk about wwe
not china but uh uh lita which one's
that oh with the hearty boys boys yeah
you know
oh you didn't [ __ ] your fitness crush
what get your [ __ ] leader
dude
she's kind of she's kind of dark kind of
girl swanton bomb she's kind of angry
you know
she probably does the tango i don't
remember i remember leaving the party
boys what do the hardy boys do they
throw out the shotgun or something
that much the shotgun she looks like
ginger spice though yeah you ever uh
jack off at your gym
the one i own no no any gym no no no no
no barbell sure this morning yeah their
bathrooms are more private
they have great bathrooms get carried
away after a lesson to start [ __ ]
beating it
i have to get a pr how does it happen
blood goes elsewhere you do any roids
before never never never you always want
to try every day in my life
why don't you have it if you want to try
it so bad why don't you do it um like
you said you can recover quickly on
conviction every day of my life not
every day my life that was exaggerated
but often often i think all fitness
dudes who haven't done it yet think
about it think about it every day uh
from a business standpoint there's no
way it hurts i'm only gonna look better
and be stronger some more [ __ ] um you
get harder boners i heard too
potentially and potentially doesn't work
either yeah potentially
potentially discharge out of your ass
randomly yeah there's a lot of negatives
um worth it yeah that's not bad yeah i
hate needles i hate noodles and then
like like when i dig into like you know
my spirit or whatever i know like it
wouldn't make me happier like getting
stronger actually wouldn't make me a
better person what makes you happier
[ __ ] broccoli which finger do you dig
in your spirit with
[Laughter]
metal
what would make you happier then
more [ __ ] today's video is brought to
you by hellotushi let me ask you a
serious question about life okay
when you
do do right
and afterwards let's say you're wiping
and then you get a little bit of doodoo
crust on your palm on my palm right yeah
do you just get a paper towel and wipe
it off like that and go about your day
or do you wash your hand with water wash
my hands yeah right yeah so why are you
doing that to your butthole why do you
why do you get paper
scrape and smear kaka all over your
booty hole and then
go about your day
that's disgusting especially since i
know one of my wife's favorite fetishes
is smelling my underwear oh i want to
make sure that my underwear smells fresh
no matter what she likes used underwear
she likes used but not skid mark
underwear
underwear ah
and one of the things i discover these
days i think i have eggs in my butthole
yeah so it itches and it feels irritated
so having hello touchy
rinse my butt make it nice and clean and
so i only have to just dab it at the end
feels so good because i'm not scraping
it with toilet paper and what i like
about hello tushy is that after i use i
barely use any toilet paper yeah because
you don't have to it rinses the crap out
of your butt and all you're doing is
dabbing the water because it's like a
jet car wash you know you don't use a
garden hose you use a high power hose
that blasts all the [ __ ] dust away
the dookie and that's how we use the
bidet we blast the dookie away yep
so if you want to blast your dookie away
feel fresh have a clean bidet experience
check out hello toushi it's freaking
awesome you don't even need to plug it
in or anything goes right into your
toilet go to hellotushy.com off the
record to get 10 off plus free shipping
and this is a special offer for our
listeners only 10 off plus free shipping
hellotushy.com
off the record and when you get it don't
forget to take a picture tag hello she
show everyone your nice bidet setup not
your butt no no no no just the bidet
yeah i mean i think it makes everybody
happy
temporarily yeah it's not gonna yeah
what's the what's the weirdest place
you've jacked off at
nowhere that weird i don't have any like
fantasies or like sex weird spots either
so you're telling me you never jacked
off on the toilet before oh no not
sitting down what about a porn potty no
so kneeling over it uh yeah yeah like
horny bro
no bro i'm not with you on this no i
want to be i want to help you but i've
been in the board i'm 100 with you i
would not drink
that you're only talking to the white
guy about this well because you you
looked at joe when it was happening so i
thought you're on tv yeah
everything i thought you were a team to
take a [ __ ]
like this yeah
no
if i don't pee sitting down i'm not
going to touch myself sitting down you
never you don't believe me what does
that have to do with sitting down you're
[ __ ] sitting down you've never seen a
porno or masturbating on my ass if i was
going to dildo myself maybe i would
you've never seen you've never seen porn
where a guy sitting on the toilet and
the girls riding him on top yeah maybe i
haven't but that makes more sense wait
so do you jack off in a urinal
no there's not a urinal at my house get
off the toilet and go to a urinal
[ __ ]
is a toilet that normal for y'all yeah
dude this guy's reverse cowgirl in a
toilet he has no [ __ ] right to talk
about anything
you guys are gross dude it's actually a
better position if you think about it
because you have something to wrap up
well you [ __ ] beat off and you just
shoot your [ __ ] nut into the bowl
i wasn't thinking about beating off you
time it you time the flesh with the
shooting so you can hit the hit in the
back of the throat
porcelain princess damn you're [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of that toilet bro i think
we got different definitions of hot you
take that you you [ __ ] american
standard
you're so nice
porcelain [ __ ] i'm sending the
questions right back to us yeah
take that you toto
how many questions do we ask and how
many questions revolve jacking up all of
them
like five or five right who's generating
the jack off questions because i don't
think i did not mean i'm just reading my
cue cards right there
i don't know
all right biggest [ __ ] regret of your
life oh [ __ ]
involving jacking off no no no it's not
not location
i want him to cry on this [ __ ] now time
to break it down man crying including
jack
dude let's get deep man you guys talk
about jacking off too much
sickos i don't know if there's like one
but i went through uh like a five-year
phase where i lost like just a lot of
people to death and suicide that sounds
boring as [ __ ] bro you wanted me to cry
just kidding i'm just kidding i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry let's get serious let's
get serious uh i don't i have like a
regret but like you always look back
like oh i wish i would have hung with
that more i wish i could have talked
that dude more i wish i would have done
this more yeah yeah it's like one of the
kids i coached i was really close so it
was a crazy year of just math five years
yeah passing away yeah like my best
friend was 18. uh dad a couple years
later best friend's mom a couple years
later kid i coached committed suicide a
little bit later a mentor died a couple
years later it was pretty weird wow so
like so that's like a three year period
about probably four years left non-stop
close people yeah i guess a regret in
some ways is i i just stopped like
answering texts and going to funerals i
didn't go to my medicine it got too
overwhelming yeah my mom called me i
didn't go to my kid's funeral who i
coached i trained him in strength
conditioning coach for basketball i just
couldn't i was like no bro like i just
came up
for some stupid reason and i get it
everyone needs to heal we had like three
funerals for my dad she's from ohio so
we did like one for the community here
we did a private one here uh just family
and then we did one in ohio and then
after i'm not going to a [ __ ] funeral
ever again in my life did a part of you
feel like regretful for not going
probably now when i look back and one of
my uh my one of my mentors his son was a
really good friend of mine we had like a
heart-to-heart once about it because i
don't think he went to my dad's funeral
there i said bro i get it like yeah
it's hard to just show up sometimes yeah
it doesn't hurt me i was never offended
if no one went to my dad's funeral but
like i just can't do that
that's tough yells a lot it was a lot
because most people don't even have one
person in their life that commits
suicide uh yeah the suicide one was
weird too i don't like to think about it
yeah he was young he's 17. wow yeah do
you know what was going on are you yeah
i probably saw i coached them all year
in basketball strength conditioning is a
happy kid talk about a gaming beast
broke his helicopter halo
you just never know what's going on is
it like it's just teams just good at
hiding it like there's no signs or
whatever not that i saw damn similar to
me you know happy happy ish kid probably
had his moments but i don't know have
you had a moment with yourself about
this where you're like you know what i
forgive myself for not going because
it's totally reasonable you're just a
human being i think so i don't think i
like hold it yeah um yeah i don't think
i hold it when you said you were 17 i
was 18 with my best that's a lot to
process as an 18 year old like it's hard
to [ __ ] carry that kind of burden you
like just graduated high school so that
was like good and bad because like all
the homies were still around it happened
in the summer so we could kind of like
get some closure together we all like
just hung out and figured it out so that
helped a little bit but i don't think
anyone ever knows like the next person
that dies in my life i'm not gonna be
any better at it yeah you don't get
better at funerals or love or you don't
get you know like
i think you do my the last dog i died i
was it was like each not better
this dog was better and better huh
i guess i don't know how to say it the
right thing is happier happier what if
you want to close those dogs maybe you
weren't as close to those dogs
and i do think dogs are different humans
but yeah i mean i guess i guess
but continue slightly
you know what i mean yeah yeah like if
you lost let's say you had two sisters
and you equally loved them both after
the second one dies like you don't get
better at like oh yeah
i know steve really would have been
devastated for a little sister yeah i
would i would need some time alone for
sure you know what with my sister's
corpse that's kind of like
i'm surprised you you even have a sister
you got a sister yeah i did she's hot as
[ __ ]
i said you got a hot sister yeah she's
really high yeah are she single
looking like she's she's a lot she got a
lot of ease and vibes
how do you think about sitting down
jerk-offs
uh
you know she's seen me [ __ ] toilet
that's for sure
i hate you guys i don't know i don't
know how to get out of that you know
i was gonna be my closer for him
i'm surprised that you didn't go
did you spiral down depression or
anything like that because that's that's
basically three or four years of
mourning yeah and then at at some point
you know just just
like hormonally like chemically you get
used to that state state right of
whatever that becomes your normal yeah
and then um
it's like you basically don't have any
serotonin at that point like what the
[ __ ] uh therapists think like i'm doing
it like now
like you're working through it now when
dad died like i just hop into like
protect her mom and take her mom yeah
yeah yeah so i didn't really agree about
it or they think yeah what do i know
yeah i think that's helpful sometimes i
think so too because my mind was
distracted yeah i don't know yeah yeah
yeah i'm self-aware-ish and i try to do
therapy and not be a psycho and i think
that distraction especially when it
comes to distraction through like love
yeah you know like taking care of your
mom yeah yeah yeah that's a positive
yeah positive distraction versus like
distracting yourself like video games of
like you killing more people or
something you know that's like kind of
also why they think i spiral down is
because like i didn't have like a vice
like it's not like oh i became an
alcoholic or i became pop not that
that's better but some people like can
find some escape in that have a phase
sure and then get out of it but like i
don't really like those things yeah so
yours was like lifting you have
otherwise other than lifting i those
buttons uh not really even lifting's
like not even one like i don't feel
better it's like i actually talk [ __ ] on
the people that are like jim is my
therapy and i'm like all right
therapy is therapy
you need it more than we
mort's heard that right like everybody
everyone i don't need a therapist
because i got [ __ ] weights they teach
me everything about life go [ __ ]
yourself but the whole reason they're
building those muscles is to protect
themselves from the world that hurt them
right yeah they're a little bunny rabbit
yeah
[Laughter]
you see these the reason why i [ __ ]
do this [ __ ]
that's why no one likes lifting weights
because those guys you know they ruin it
for everybody dude the guys also who who
go ah and they drop the [ __ ] weights
i hate those [ __ ] dude when do
i drop weights dude man i do that [ __ ]
with five pounders bro
i just i'm loud look at this guy he
slams the [ __ ] barbell i [ __ ]
break the mirror and then like
he really does do that right mike i have
one more question for you all right
how beneficial do you think therapy has
helped you with your mental health and
all that stuff and how often do you go
so i stopped going because of covid like
all the doctors just shut down but i
used to go once or twice a week and then
it depends on your budget um i honestly
don't know
if it helps
but what i do think uh is you can learn
a lot you learn about yourself you learn
about other humans yeah it doesn't think
yeah yeah yeah for sure but it's not
like
you know it's not like it when i like
you're more aware but doesn't mean that
it's solved yeah well last time i went
it was like two three years ago and i
was in a pretty dark spot uh just like
sitting on the couch literally couldn't
move if i wanted to um so like forced
myself my mom honestly made the
appointment i didn't even go my mom made
the appointment said would you go and i
said
and then she made the appointment i
drove myself but like i wouldn't go and
uh
going didn't like make me feel better
it's not like oh i'm fixed yeah you know
but it's like a long problem you do it
for five years yes it definitely helps
you know because you learn and whatever
um
but i don't know i don't really know
because i think everyone's so different
it's a good thing not to
you know walk around being like well i'm
i'm fixed now you know there's nobody
nobody's fixed like
it's always work right like always
everything you actually even do
something about it is like 90 of it
probably yeah yeah because you don't
have weights as your therapist that's
like the meme right like uh paradise uh
[ __ ] what does it go like something
about um
the people
i go to therapy because of people that
don't go to therapy
[Music]
for sure yeah yeah for sure because if
everybody went we'd all be chilling but
i gotta go to therapy because of
whatever sounds like the vaccine to me
yeah you made me sick
i gotta admit though i i just met you
today yeah and you seem like a stellar
dude so whatever you've been going
through
nice to meet you that's right good to
meet you too bro there it is you ever
[ __ ] a urinal before
[Laughter]
wait can we just end it with how many
people actually jerk off sitting down
i really don't want to know bro
wait wait wait wait i'm joking are you
like
yeah yeah yeah on the toilet is it just
the toilet or how about a chair no
chairs no chad's different no he's
talking about a toilet i'm not
encouraging this dude
a clean house was jacked off on a toilet
when that was the only place you could
check out
[Music]
you